the us invaded afghanistan in october
2001 in response to terror attacks
now 20 years later we still had a
presence and abruptly withdrew all
troops
what do you think about this war across
the world
that was uh sparked by this tragedy
whenever you do something quickly
without thinking it out thinking it
through and planning
it doesn't succeed
i understand that we needed to exit
i mean how how long we're going to stay
over there and and we've lost over 7 000
of our young souls
over there
for sometimes people i don't know if
they're grateful for it or not right i i
mean
i don't know
so there's the other element and sorry
to interrupt that's okay one is the
financial of six trillion dollars and
that money is not just money it's it's
education it's everything um
it's money that could have gone towards
first of all the first responders oh
yeah but all the service men and women
of all kinds throughout this country and
then there's the other side which is the
over 800 000 people who died in direct
uh result of this conflict so not just
the american side of the troops but just
people who died humans humans yeah and
those humans
um many of them civilians
that's spreading hate
especially if you have leaders on the
other side who frame the death of those
civilians in certain ways that just
spreads hate throughout the world and so
you think about this
kind of um 20-year saga and think
what are the ways that money could have
spent be spent better
and what was the way that we could
spread more love in the world versus
hate
and you wonder
but then the the other side
uh
what is it i'm not sure who says this
line but um
it's something like
we sleep at night because there's uh
rough men out there ready to
to fight for you
there is some sense in which we have to
make sure
that there's strength coupled with the
love
right otherwise evil
men um
will do evil onto the world so it's a
very difficult decision but then you
look at the final picture it's like what
have we gotten for the six trillion
dollars what have we gotten for this 20
years
the the thousands of americans soldiers
who died
the uh the hundreds of thousands of uh
civilians who have died
you know it's it's a
it's a troubling subject for me um i'm a
patriot i love this country
i love it so with my soul
and uh i was
just about to head over to the first
iraqi war and we went out for desert
warfare training and then it ended i was
at that time a combat medic assigned to
an armored cav unit so basically tanks
driving around an armored personnel
carrier and when it gets hit then you
you tend to that guy try to save his
life
i didn't want to go
i may sound like a coward i did not want
to go to war
i would have went
willingly if i was sent to defend my
country i took my oath
i didn't join the military to kill
but if necessary i would
i'll use the analogy of cancer
if you have a cancer and you're aware of
its presence
and you don't annihilate those cells
and take them out
quickly
it's going to spread
and it's going to kill you
those evil bastards
that flew those airplanes
one of those airplanes had a little
three-year-old child in it from ireland
where my mom's hometown
a friend of mine who since died of a
heart attack from 9 11 toxins he found
her shoe
with human remains in it
and he thought someone was messing with
us because we didn't know there was any
kids in the building he says boss this
this this is a baby shoe and it looks
like there's something in it but but
there's no kids in the trade center i
went
the plane
it's a little girl's shoe
i can never get that shoe out of my mind
the evil bastards who perpetrated that
needed to have missiles strike and rain
down upon them and annihilate them like
a cancer that they are
what what just fascinates me is they'll
show videos of these guys flying around
and pick up trucks with 50 cows on the
back it's like well wait a minute if a
camera crew can get this footage
you think all these freaking drones and
planes and radar assisted systems can't
just go
good night you're gone
so kill the cancer kill the cells get
rid of it get rid of it quickly
and go into remission like an undeniable
show of force that sends a message that
uh gets rid of most
of the obvious centers of um terrorism
and that no that's though because we
offline mention a discussion with jocko
and
maybe a romanticized view
and mentioning brothers in arms by dire
straits and saying we're all brothers in
arms
even when it's on the opposite side of
fighting
which is more of a vision and growing up
in the soviet union you saw about world
war ii yes that it's all just kids
thrown into the
kids sent to die in all sides
but then
presenting that to jocko
who was uh in iraq
he did not see
as brothers in arms
which is there's
his basic statement is there's evil
people
and some people don't deserve the
compassion you give them a few chances
they don't take the chances they have to
go because they're spreading evil onto
the world and so it's not we're not
all of us deserve a chance
oh no but uh but the difference though
and and believe me i i jockle i am from
a way way
minor league compared to him right i
mean this man was right there in the
firing line but
i can understand his analogy because
when you think about it right those
young conscripts back in germany and
russia and you know all the countries
where they were being drafted even our
guys were being drafted and thrown into
this
they were
they were gallantly and and bravely
defending their country now
i'm sure the the young germans felt well
hey hitler must be right
right and young russians fell hey stalin
must be right and you know the young
americans figure hey president roosevelt
must be right
so they
were romantically in a sense defending
the honor of their country of their
motherland the difference between those
so they did have that commonality if you
and i were firing across each other from
france to germany or you know from
germany to russia
we're just these two kids who got thrown
into this we didn't freaking ask for
this right but the difference with
jocko's enemy is
no one was attacking their country over
there right
no one was taking their country over
maybe in their mind they didn't want
people trying to build their government
this and that i don't i don't know i
don't know enough about the history
there to to really elaborate
we didn't attack them
and
if a soldier attacks a soldier that's an
understood concept amongst warriors but
when a soldier attacks a civilian now
you're after a different beast
and you've written that beast off if
that makes any sense yeah and and then
the the enemy i mean
as jocko explains the the enemy uh in
iraq and just uh certain parts of the
middle east
is um essentially
terrorists who are
who don't value the lives of the
civilians of their own country they
don't and so it becomes like this weird
guerrilla warfare slash game of violence
that
ultimately allows them to gain more
power within their country but they
don't care if they're playing with
civilian lives as pawns if you have a
child who dies
on their on um that's a civilian in
their country that could be seen as a
positive for them because they can use
that to leverage for more and more power
within that country absolutely when
you're fighting an enemy like that
that's a vicious that's an evil enemy
absolutely it's like snakes are
beautiful but if you go pet a rattler
you're getting bit and you're getting
dead right yeah and that's with
terrorists you've got to cut the head of
the snake off
you